[Music]
there's a weird phenomenon I've noticed
all throughout my life where the more I
subject myself to discomfort the happier
I am
I think this phenomenon became
increasingly apparent to me in first
year of university where I wanted to
make the best impression possible you
know typical freshman behavior it's a
new school new network of people new
city so I really felt a need to reinvent
who I was as a human being especially on
a kind of social skills basis so in
order to do that I was forcing myself
outside of my comfort zone so frequently
it's as if it was some sort of game it's
like I was able to peel back a layer of
reality and see some sort of one-to-one
relationship between subjecting myself
to discomfort and upgrading who I was as
a human being now that I'm in my old age
I don't necessarily think that is a
one-to-one relationship more on that
later but I was definitely onto
something
because I felt incredible I was
energetic optimistic I remember waking
up in the morning not being tired
because I was ready to tackle the day
with energy and although this euphoria
didn't last forever I never forgot how I
felt
and I remember the importance of viewing
the comfort zone and the effect it has
on your overall well-being and the way
you live your life so in this video
we're going to talk about a few things
that I've learned about the comfort zone
and how I think if you can gain a better
understanding of how the comfort zone
works you can start living life on your
terms instead of its terms because it
has a lot more control over the way you
live your life then you might think so
here are some things that I've
discovered about the comfort zone and
hopefully you can apply them to your
life as well so everything you're
physically capable of doing in this
world falls into one of two categories
inside the comfort zone or outside the
comfort zone the things that are inside
the comfort zone are easy for you to do
comfortable they take little or no
effort to do and there's pretty much no
mental resistance in the way of doing
that thing like driving for a lot of
people driving is completely in the
comfort
you know you drive to work you drive to
your house you drive to the store to
pretend to buy vitamins so they can get
footage for this video
since driving is so easy at one point or
another your brain went and
subconsciously placed it inside the
comfort zone so you don't really think
about doing it before you do it it's
just something you do okay
how about going for a run a lot harder
isn't it it's more physically strenuous
requires more preparation it makes you
lose your breath or sweat and if you
haven't ran for a while you'll probably
be really sore the next day and because
you know running is physically strenuous
and hard to do your brain at one point
or another when placed it outside the
comfort zone the further outside the
comfort zone something is the more
mental resistance there is in the way of
doing that thing but here's where things
get kind of interesting running is good
for you after a week of running every
day you can find that your mental energy
increases your outlook on life is better
and more optimistic and after a week of
driving you kind of feel nothing it's
just driving so there really isn't a
clear-cut relationship between things
that are inside the comfort zone outside
the comfort zone and the value that
these things have on your life
in fact the comfort zone is terrible at
telling you what's good for you and
what's bad for you what activities you
should adopt into your life and what
activities you should avoid so let's
take walking for example walking is
probably inside your comfort zone and
running is outside of it but it doesn't
mean that walking is bad for you in the
same way stabbing yourself in the leg
with a pencil is probably outside of
your comfort zone but doesn't mean it's
good for you so there really isn't a
clear-cut relationship between things
that are inside the comfort zone outside
the comfort zone and the value that
these things have on your life all the
comfort zone is concerned with is
keeping you inside of it and the way it
does that is not only does it make sure
that things outside of it are really
uncomfortable and hard to do it's also
always shrinking if you don't do
anything about it unless you venture at
least a little bit beyond the borders of
the comfort zone it will get smaller and
harder to escape and this is something
that most people have experienced in
their lives whether they are aware of it
or not in my
life this happens all the time like when
halo 5 came out a few years ago I spent
so much time just playing it for hours
and hours every day eating Doritos sweet
chili heat and drinking Mountain Dew
like a real gamer and after days of
doing this binging a video game and not
doing anything outside of my comfort
zone things that were previously just on
the edge of my comfort zone like going
to the gym the comfort zone shrank to a
point where going to the gym was now
extremely difficult and very hard to
bring myself to do you may have also
experienced this type of thing where
maybe you're on vacation and it's sort
of one of those sit around and don't
really do much vacations
you're kind of on your phone a lot on a
couch maybe the weather is really nice
and you start to become soft you know
you don't really want to do many
interesting things or very hard things
or anything that will take much effort
you kind of just become a blob you feel
pathetic okay so what have we learned
we've learned that in order to keep the
comfort zone from shrinking we have to
do things that are outside of the
comfort zone to keep the comfort zone
large but we also learned that the
comfort zone in general is a pretty
terrible guide for telling us what to do
with their life what activities are
useful to us and what activities don't
really do anything so basically we need
a solution to this problem we need a
more reliable guide for making decisions
and I think you can't go wrong with
making values based decisions your
values figure out what kind of person
you want to be what kind of traits you
want to adopt what kind of skills you
want to learn and make your decisions
based off of that and using the
knowledge of the comfort zone be aware
that any potential discomfort in the way
of doing the thing that you want to do
isn't a real obstacle it's all just in
your head if you live life this way the
comfort zone can also work in your favor
because as you start living this new
lifestyle that may have at first been
unnatural to you the longer you live
that way the comfort zone is expanding
to meet you so living the way you want
to live will become increasingly natural
and dare I say comfortable so to bring
this whole thing back to my freshman
year it's becoming clear to me that the
reason I felt so good wasn't necessarily
because I was just uncomfortable all the
time
the reason I felt so good was because I
was living the life that I wanted to
live and I disregarded discomfort
altogether and when you no longer let
discomfort have a say in how you make
any of your decisions the potential for
what you can do with your life expands
dramatically so you guys may have
noticed that a lot of the b-roll shots
today were quite cinematic that was
because I was able to rent a Sony FX 9
which is a Netflix approved cinema
camera and I was only able to do that
because of Awesome sponsors like
Skillshare which is a really relevant
sponsor to today's video topic
especially if you use the classes to
help you develop skills you really want
to work on for instance I'm currently
taking storytelling and film using
cinematography to convey emotion by Joe
Simon which is directly relevant to the
cinematography skill I'm trying to
develop for those of you who don't know
skill share is an online learning
community with thousands of classes
covering countless topics everything
from self-improvement to photography
videography productivity with so much to
explore real projects to create and the
support of fellow creatives Skillshare
empowers you to accomplish real growth
all of their classes are designed for
real life so you can easily apply
whatever you're learning on Skillshare
into your real life pursuits it's also
extremely affordable especially when you
compare it to in-person workshops and
master classes with an annual membership
it costs less than $10 a month
Skillshare is doing this awesome thing
where the first 500 of you who click the
link in the description below get two
months of skill show premium absolutely
free so make sure you hit that up
explore your creativity and as usual
have a great time if you like this video
make sure to hit like because when you
hit like the algorithm blesses me by
shoving this video in front of other
people's faces helping them out which
also helps me out and the channel spread
its love no I'm not gonna say that
that's crazy needless to say at this
point if you're lurking here and you
watch a lot of the videos and you
haven't subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting the bell icon so
that you don't miss future videos
anyways that's all for today thank you
for watching and we'll catch you in the
next video
you